هنا العراق هنا البصره هنا خليجي في
بطولته 25 تنظيم مبهر وحفل افتتاحا فقط
توقعات استضافته البصره التي رحبت بكرمها
المعتاد بابناء الخليج والذين حلوا فيها
اخوه واشيقه واصحاب بلد اخرين البصره
المدينه الساحره في بلاد الرافدين ومهد
الحضارات العراقيه كانت على موعد مع حفل
ضخم شهيده العالم وباركه وابناء الخليج
بحضورهم للبطوله الخاصه بهم المزيد مع
زينب النشاد
راحين على المصراوي
صارت اجمل هنا بعد ان ضم الخليج بعضه
لحضني بعض وسعاده العراقيين اشربت من ظلام
انتظار طويل وخجل وانطلقت اخيرا بطوله كاس
الخليج بدورتها الخامسه والعشرين بعد
تاجيل استمر لاربع دورات سابقا الحدث لم
يكن رياضيا فقط الحدث كان اجتماعيا
وسياسيا ايضا وتضمن قصص طروه على لقاء جاء
بعض طول تراب
يا مرحبا هلا بيكم هلا هلا هلا
نورتوا ديرتكم هلا بالناس الطيبه هلا هلا
هلا هلا
النور شو عادت مغنيه فوق شط العرب وكان
العوده اصابت كل شيء في العراق حتى سكانها
على اختلافهم لنجد ايزيديه بعشيقه وابناء
الموصل وشبا ميسانيا مولعا بعروض كره
القدم كلهم جاءوا داعمينا للفرحه
واخويا ومجموعه من الاصدقاء المسافه
الديوانيه اتجنن احنا اهل البصره تقدم
البطوله البطوله الخليجي 25
استعراض استعراض في الشوارع
العراق
والبيوت لهم واحتضنت الجدران اعلام
الوافدين تمتزجت الثقافات ولا نستغرب ان
اضعنا هويه عراقيه ارتدى الزي العماني او
العكس فالعراق التفح باعلام زائريه وبث في
نفوسهم السلامه والطمانينه
وكل الشرف من الدول العربيه كلها بس العشق
السلطنه عمان احب سلطنه عمان وتولعت اكثر
شيء بسلطنه عمان لانه دوله راقيه وحبيت
سيارات عمان ونوع السيارات اللكزس 400
معروفه عند عمان
[موسيقى]
القلق الذي احاط بالزائرين قبل مجيئهم زال
وصاروا يفكرون بزياره اخرى كما نرى
صفوان
نشكر في اهل البصره واهل صفوان واهل
الزبير العراق بشكل عام يعني على ضيافه
حسن الضيافه الاستقبال امانه كان استقبال
طيب ااه وسعيدين بزياره البصره
وما لقينا منهم لك الخير
25 كان اهل يقولوا لي ايش يوديك للعراق
الحمد لله اول ما عديت حدود العراق
عكس التوقعات عكس الكلام اللي يقولونه
الناس شفنا هنا الامان وشفنا هنا
الاجواء الحلوه انا من السعوديه
واول مره صراحه يزور البصره وزوروا اراك
الحاضرين بل فاجئ الكثيرين قدم خلاله
البلد المضيف عرضا اختصر فيه تاريخه
الكبير وحضارته وحاضره الذي يحمل املا لم
ينضب مهما توالت الخيبات زينب المشاط صباح
العربيه البصره
على كلنا بقع في البصره مع مراسله صباح
العربيه زينب المشاط زينب يسعد صباحك
صباحك اهلا بك معنا حدثينا اكثر عن مهد
الحضارات عن حاضنه خليجي 25 البصره حيث
انت
طبعا مثل ما يقولون البصراويه صباحك
بصراويات طبعا اليوم اطل عليك من منطقه
الكورنيش اييه شارع الكورنيش في البصره
هذا شارع يطل على شط العرب ويعتبر من اكبر
شوارع البصره تقريبا هنا بالتحديد همم
ملتقى المشجعين في البصره يتوفر بالمشجعين
تقريبا بعد الساعه 11:00 صباحا ايه يقتضي
الشارع بالمشجعين في هذا الوقت ويبقى
المشجعين تقريبا الى همم ساعه الساعه
الرابعه بعد منتصف الليل همم لهذا
المحافظه اعلى من خلال الاسبوع همم
يعني اعطت اجازه للمواطنين في البصره
محافظه البصره نعم طب كيف يعني
25 كيف كان توافق الجمهور العراقي
والخليجي كيف كانت الاصداء
كان التوافق كبير جدا طبعا لنستغرب انه
المشجع السعودي يرتدي العلم العراقي ويشجع
الفريق العراقي ولا نستغرب ان المباراه
الاولى بين عمان وبحرين طبعا كان بين
العراق العراق وعمان كانت
يعني المشجعين العمانيين يشجعون العراق
والمشجعين العراقيين يشجعون عمان حقيقه
الموضوع لم يكن همم الموضوع لن يدور حول
الكره على نفسها الموضوع كان يدور حول من
العراق غاب عن الخليج على مدى 44 عام بعد
اولى بعد همم بطوله كاس الخليج التي اقيمت
في سبعينيات القرن الماضي همم العراق
تقريبا 44 عام واليوم عاده همم من جديد
الى الخليج
هذه البطلان المنتخبات الثمانيه الخارجيه
تعود للبصره بعد حظر الملاعب العراقيه دام
وقت طويل بسبب الواقع الامريكي كيف يبدو
الواقع الامن اليوم وامليا كيف تحت هذه
البطوله
يعني الواقع الامني ممتاز حقيقته همم
الخليجين انفسهم يعني همم اشاد بذلك ذكروا
ان ال- الامن مستتب في البيئه البلاد ان
ما يصلهم من احاديث لم تكن صحيحه نهائيه
العراق العراقيون همم انتهزوا هذه الفرصه
لتوجيه رساله الى العالم كله وليس الى
الخليج فقط ان ما يقال ويشاع- لا يشبه
العراقيين هناك من الحب وهنالك كم من
القلوب الطيبه و هنالك من الكرم الكبير
همم الذي همم
يعني يستعد العراقي
لكل من يزورهم لكل من ياتي اليهم ولكل من
يحبهم همم اضافه الى هذا يعني همم الشهر
هذا شارع الكون ستجدين الكثير من المصريين
يقفون ويحمدون لافتات يعني مكتوب عليها
بالحرف الواحد انا بصراوي وابحث عن ضيف
خليجي لاضيفه منزلي اا المضايف افتتحت
ابوابها على مدى 24 ساعه ابتداءا من منطقه
من قضاء الزبير وحتى قلب البصره همم
والافتتاح كما شاهدناه كان افتتاح همم
اشيد به سواء من المتابعين عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي او اا من خلال الحاضرين
للافتتاح انفسهم هناك قليل جدا من الهفوات
طبعا همم لكن
الخليجيين والعراقيين اتفقوا على ان لا
همم ينظر او يبصروا لهذه فوات
وانشغلوا بهذا الحفل الكبير هذا الحفل
الذي يعني اعتبره ال- ال- الخليجيين
والعراقيين هو خطوه همم للم الشمل مثل ما
يعني قائد خاصه وان الغياب كان طويل جدا
بالمره الجايه بالمدينه الرياضيه داخل
الملعب البصره نشوفك احدى المباريات شكرا
زينب المشاط من البصره